what's your opinion on the madness of
wall street vets and
wall street at the moment uh it's
it's the same the same kind of
um phenomena as gamergate
uh where you have the the the vast
collection of small people
looking up at the giant institution and
saying well
why them and not me and then when they
start making any kind of motions
the giant institution moves to protect
its interest which means
breaking the rules and acting
arbitrarily
acting a way that nobody really expected
them to act um
like robin hood ceasing the the buying
of gme shares
that's i mean that was just done purely
to protect robin hood as a company
it wasn't even to protect wall street
because they had this vulnerability
because everything has limits i suppose
but there's obviously i think that
there's probably um
shenanigans going on behind the scenes
at this point because i think they've
realized oh my god
this is actually this is cost wall
street in total something like 70
billion dollars
and that's massive you know for a bunch
of idiots on reddit who have just spent
a few hundred bucks buying a couple of
cheapo shares
that are not really worth anything
anyway but it's
it's the will that's behind it that's
important isn't it it's the oppositional
will
and i think that essentially what the
i guess i will generally characterize as
the elite in any
sphere of life right it could be
politics which is why we get donald
trump
it could be gamergate and video games
which is why gaming get occurred
it could be uh in trading and stocks
which is why it's
you know wall street bets and the game
stunks revolt
um and it i've seen many people in other
different
uh walks of life in minor ways finding
themselves
diametrically opposed to the elite class
and the elite class essentially have to
come to the table
and admit that they have accrued more
than is
justifiable in some terms and in some
ways and this is not always money or
anything like that this is
that what what we're talking about
really is just the
sort of abstract and almost indefinable
uh or unquantifiable uh concept of power
and influence um the the little guys
feel that they don't have
the influence they deserve and that's
probably true and the big guys
feel that the influence that they have
accrued is
being attacked and being taken from them
which is also true
uh but the question is is there a
justified
rebalancing that can take place and i
think a consensual
conversation about how these things
could be made more fair
is definitely preferable to the kind of
civic war that we're going to see
happening between
groups of people within the same
industries
and so far this has not been handled
well
so far it has been a kind of social war
between the various factions and they
don't end well it costs everyone lots of
money
it's lots of stress people lose things
and
it it really turns out well and it just
bodes towards
uh it's kind of a downward spiral where
these things if they're not resolved
to the general satisfaction just
continue to increase the pressure so the
next time the event is bigger and bigger
and this is why
like gamergate i would say was probably
about 50 000 people at its height
which is actually really small for the
video game industry but
when you when you you know scaling this
up to the wall street bets thing
you can tell that there's a lot of the
same people who
supported gamergate and various other
sort of populist uprisings like trump
who also support wall street bets even
though they're not the same people
doing it and they're not interested in
that sphere of life
um but the the you can see the pressures
ramping up and like the wall street bets
thing has been huge
uh their subreddit was something like
2.8 million when it started
and now it's over 6 million so it's like
you can see the
just the graph shoot up in the number of
people who are interested
in this thing and who want to take part
in pushing back against what they view i
think rightly
as a kind of ignorant detached and
self-interested elite class
it's not new all throughout history this
has happened it's been a common
thing and this is just the 21st century
iteration of this
and so here we are the difference is now
that you've got the ability to
coordinate
so effectively the proletariat can now
gather on
mass and they can do things instantly
and there's
no matter how big the hedge fund is
we've seen here power
in numbers on the internet timed
correctly
with a little bit of manipulation of
algorithms and enough understanding
of what's going on in a lot of caffeine
like you combine those things together
and it's a subreddit like do you think
this is the sort of thing that's going
to end up with the legislation being put
in long term because this can continue
to happen this level of coordination
it's it's not even that it can continue
to happen it's that it's almost
impossible to stop correct
um especially when you don't know that
it's going to happen like the wall
street bets thing i've never heard of
wall street bets until about a week
i've been i've been following them for
around about a year they are phenomenal
they are phenomenal they're so good but
that being said i i remember looking at
it when it had 700k
or so on the on the subreddit and they
were watching people lose their life
savings on
apple like one person had a legend if
you want to go back and look at the best
stuff
youtube search dankest trades of wall
street bets and they did a quarterly
roundup
of like the most mad [ __ ] so these guys
have been doing it for a very long time
but yeah the legislation
oh yeah no no i i i i i understand
they've been doing for a while and
whatnot but it's just um when it becomes
injected into the popular consciousness
through this kind of event
you know then it suddenly uh becomes a
much bigger thing i imagine that they
probably will try to create some sort of
legislation against this
but uh but the problem is like okay
you'll legislate it's that thing but
the emotion and the impetus behind it
hasn't gone away it's like you know if
you've got a
a hose that you're piping water through
a high pressure
and the the hose springs leak and you
put your finger down on it okay but the
pressure hasn't gone away
you're just artificially preventing that
pressure from exhibiting at this point
and so it bursts up again somewhere else
you've got to put another finger down
another thing that
until the entire thing will split open
because you've just got too many uh
too many points on it that you're
holding down because the the thing that
is containing the pressure isn't
suitable to contain the pressure
which is why you're getting these
problems in the first place and so what
this requires is reform
you know it's a demand for reform when
these things happen because it shows
there's a problem with the system and
every system that's built by mankind is
going to be
flawed in some way and over time the
problems that are created by those flaws
build up until they're unacceptable and
the system has to change
this is just the the nature of human
planning
um and it would i think be wiser for
those people who currently benefit from
the system
to accept that that is a an immutable
reality of things that men build and
roll with the punches rather than become
authoritarian and start clamping down
and
you know legislate oh we have to protect
ourselves because then
i mean it's not even it's not even just
that hey this isn't going to work in the
long run it'll work in the short run
but it was not going to work in the long
run and it might end up quite nastily in
the long run
but um it's not just that it's it shows
that you aren't
really um accountable and it shows that
you aren't really interested in a good
faith
uh society and that's the basis of civil
society
rather than rather than any kind of like
um
ancient or monarchical or oppressive
society what we have in the west is what
we call a civil society and that's a
consensual society
society into which we all enter and
agree on a certain set of rules
so we won't have designs on our
neighbors and our neighbours won't have
designs on us
and we'll be able to operate freely and
consensually through voluntary
interactions and in transactions
governed by fair laws and we can all
just get on with our lives and that
sounds really appealing doesn't it uh
but as soon as you get an elite class
that's like actually no you can't do
these things that we can do
we've got rules that you don't have then
it becomes right so we've got
you know an evil and ill will that
underpins this thing and then it becomes
uncomfortable because but then people
have got designs on what you have
because they don't think you have it
fairly
because you don't have it fairly you got
it by having a rule for you and a rule
for them
and never the twain should meet and so
it's it creates
instability in the system and when it
gets to this point we've just got
an open public revolt that's just
essentially burning money to hurt
wall street okay you've got you've gone
wrong you've gone wrong something has
been messed up you need to come to the
table
you know get get the wall street bets
guys to just elect
you know representatives tell them look
elect like five people
that you guys can trust you know and
then send them to our headquarters we'll
sit down
we'll live stream the debate you will
live stream the negotiations so everyone
can see it's totally transparent and
we'll
what do you want what do we want and
we'll try and come to a compromise and
that way people could feel like they won
both sides could feel like they won
something you know the wall street guys
would feel they
they're not about like they've got armed
guards at the the ball
outside wall street now it's like look
if you need armed guards
for just you know a private institution
it's not working yeah exactly you
you're doing something that people hate
and you should stop
you know uh so but i mean no that's not
gonna happen this is
yeah it would be
[Music]
yeah and i asked him about anarchy and
kind of how it works and what it means
and uh [ __ ] me if it doesn't explain a
lot like he was talking about
when you see the powers that be take the
gloves off
that's when you realize actually they
don't care about you they'll give you
the semblance
of a piece of cheese for every time that
you do a little trick
up until the point at which you you find
a way around
the cheese game and you manage to get
the whole wheel and then they'll come in
with a hammer and hit you over the head
and as you said just there it's not a
long-term
viable strategy if you decide to scale
this
over time trust gets raised you can in
one event erase decades of trust with
the people
or with an industry or with a community
or whatever and um
yeah man i and that's that's bad that's
the
that's where a stable society starts
becoming unstable
i mean i'm i'm not an anarchist but i
can accept that that is a legitimate
anarchist critique
of a state and you know large-scale
systems
and it is a legitimate anarchist
critique um
and so it needs to be it needs to be
spoken about one of michael malus's
strong points i've
i've only watched a few uh live streams
like tim paul and joe rogan and things
like this
um but one of the things that he's
really good at is identifying the will
that underpins
actions you know he's in you i it took
me a while to notice that why his
critiques were so incisive
and it's because he's addressing this
will that becomes self-evident when you
actually look at the actors
that are taking actions yeah this you
know you don't do these things
from a position of good faith you know
you just don't do that
and uh and he's really good at
identifying that that's why i love
people
that are bothered about the individual
michael's very very concerned about
personal sovereignty and individual
agency and upward mobility and stuff
like that but he has
the broader spectrum spectrum
understanding so you can see the big
picture you can see that paradigm
but he's concerned with individual
motivations and when you realize that
all that big stuff are
aggregates of individual stuff and you
can get right to the root of it you get
you get some some really good insights
there's a something i've been thinking
about
do you think well but before we before
we go on i just want to
you you're absolutely right though and i
just want to reinforce that by by
pointing out
this is why the communist critiques of
capitalism always fail right and this is
why
the modern communist critiques are
especially bad because they always
approach it with
businesses are purely about making money
and
that might be true if you were to
abstract the concept of a business
into a realm that is not connected to
people
and in this abstract realm you just look
at the interests of the institution
itself
but then you realize well as you say you
know everything is actually individual
action
and so when you look at the individuals
involved you realize they have ethical
motivations they have moral goals
they are not just these like soulless
corporate lunatics and we can see this
in silicon valley you know they've
adopted a kind of ideology
that gives them a license to actually
persecute some other kinds of
ideological enemies that they've
assigned
and so now it's really not about making
money you know you could you
like um youtube with the adpocalypse and
all of these other problems
like youtube and the advertisers if they
were just concerned about money
when the wall street journal is like oh
my god pewdiepie said uh
a naughty word or a made a joke about
nazis or something
they'd just shrug and go so what so what
our sales were up why do we care you
know but they didn't they all reacted
oh no that's terrible shut things down
and advertisers pull out and it's like
these are not business interests you
know youtube lost
like i know 50 70 billion something like
that they lost billions of
billions of dollars doing this so if it
was just purely about
business interest there's no way that
would have been the case and yet here we
are
and you can you know see like susan
wojcicki uh you know and listen to her
in interviews
jack dorsey mark zuckerberg they do have
moral interests and so
it is wrong for the leftists to just you
know separate those and say right never
the twain meet
because this is not true this is exactly
your point
you